Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in the book of prayer
in the chapters regarding the timings of
prayer. And yesterday we discussed the
core three times that are recurring
meaning the daily and nightly times when
salah is prohibited.
And what is meant by salah categorically
is
preferable prayer, optional prayer.
stuff that.
Not the obligatory prayers. The five
obligatory prayers
are to be made on their times. If a
person misses one by forgetting or
sleeping or unconsciousness or what have
you, then they make it as immediately as
they can upon regaining consciousness.
We discussed this. And so yesterday and
the day before in the narration of
in the narration of Abdullahbs
we mention the narration
of the three times when the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam prohibited prayer.
We mention
after fudel
until the sun rises
high moderately high in the over the
horizon
at exact noon until things develop a
shade again and just before sunset until
the sun sets and that these three times
are roughly 15 to 20 minutes for each.
So 15 minutes after sunrise, 15 minutes
before, 15 minutes before.
Now what is exempt from this? Even
optional prayers, is there an exemption
to this? Here the author takes us to a
very important
point in this chapter and in general a
general principle and that is
he tells us that
places and times
which are exempt
from this narration.
So we have a general narration, right?
And this general narration tells us
generally three times not to pray.
Well, specifically what is exempt from
this prohibition
are
certain times and places which are more
specific than this affformentioned
narration. Therefore, the aforementioned
narration becomes specified by it.
Fore
[Silence]
image.
for
[Silence]
immed
So one of the things that are exempted
from these three times
is the time just before Juma.
What do we mean by Jumra?
meaning
essentially commences. It begins
when the im
gets up onto the meim. This is referred
to as
imb
when the im stands on the
right
has officially commenced.
Then the imam sits down and then the im
the adan is called. Correct.
The author here
cites a narration which is inki
in which the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii
Wasam said, "No man will bathe on the
day of J
and
then purify himself as best as he can as
as u thoroughly as he can and then
put on whatever of lotions and whatever
of which is perfume or right
that he is able to and then goes out to
Juma and upon arriving to the masjid
does not separate between two people
what's meant by this is two people are
sitting next to each other they come and
sit between them make them both move or
come and step over them stepping over
people making them move out of the way
they came last they want to sit first
right so they these These are things
which will which will invalidate a
person's reward cuz there is a very
particular reward for Juma. These are
all conditions for that reward. He says
and then proceeds to pray as much as he
is able to as much as Allah has written
for him and then listens and is quiet
when the imam speaks.
No man will do all of these things on
the day of J except that what is between
that j and the subsequent j of sins will
be forgiven.
Right? So let us review. This is a very
specific reward.
In order for a person to be rewarded
for all of his sins between ever these
two Jumra,
this person must do the following. They
must bathe, purify themselves as best as
possible. They must put on some kind of
perfume, some kind of some kind of musk,
whatever it is, whatever there is
available.
Number three,
go to the masid and not harm anyone
with their body language, with their
position, with they do not separate
between people that are sitting next to
each other. They do not annoy people as
they come to the masjid
and then pray if they're able to until
the imam starts to speak till the imam
rises onto the mima
and then is quiet and listens.
A person picks up his phone is done.
That reward is gone.
You see this a lot. If I wish I could
have
you know those cameras that they sports
people put on their head to see what
they're seeing. If you could see what
I'm seeing on the mimb
on the day of J. It's very sad to see
how many people went to the trouble to
come to Jan
just to invalidate their reward because
they have to check their email or send a
text message or this part of the isn't
as entertaining and I need to just pick
up my phone real quick until it gets
entertaining again, right? Or I'm really
important and I definitely have an
exemption
that everyone else doesn't have. My
phone is a special phone. Everybody
else, they need to put their phone down.
But my phone, my texts are very special.
I'm an important man, you know. So I I
can't spare 20 minutes in the masid
without touching my phone. I just can't
do it. Can't do it. The world will fall
apart, right? So I have to check my
phone. I have to check my email. I have
to send this text. And so because of
that and because the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam mentioned
and we'll get to this in the chapter of
in the book of J but he says whoever
touches the the dirt or the stones on
the ground you know in the prophet's
time there wasn't carpet on the ground
right it was it was just light dirt and
you know it was a it was a dirt floor so
naturally you could, you know, doodle on
the
on the floor or, you know, play with the
stones, you know, and so people would do
that. It's not because they intended to.
It's just it's an absent-minded thing.
And the prophet sallallah.aii Wasam
said, "Whoever touches
the
gravel, the the stones the on the floor
then this person has done what is
called." And what's meant by that is he
has invalidated
his reward for Jum. In other wording, he
said, "Whoever does this leaves Ju and
goes back to his home with nothing but
two handfuls of dirt as his reward."
That's all he gets.
It's a silly thing, right? But with
Allah, it's not silly.
And this is something that I think a
lot of people don't realize and that is
that the im the run on batteries, right?
They don't have they're not a
robot. When they see people zoning out,
they zone out. It takes their
concentration away. It takes their
enthusiasm away. They feel bad. They
think I'm boring everyone. And that
becomes a feedback loop, right? the
more he becomes
you know disenchanted the more they
feel his disenchantment and so forth
until Juma becomes largely what a
formality
right a formality
and you see this it's sad that in many
mass it becomes a formality even in some
major major massagid worldwide
where I have a paper I just read it
whoever learned something learned
something. Whoever didn't didn't that's
not my problem as long as the government
doesn't give me trouble. Right? This
happens. It destroys our Juma. Juma is
supposed to be extremely enthusiastic.
People are supposed to lock in to the
im. They are supposed to pay attention.
And so in some the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said
in his
meaning, I am warning you of the fire.
And he continued to say it and repeat it
and say it louder and louder and louder
to the point that he was heard all the
way in the marketplace from the mim
saying
that was the
right. And so these small things they
invalidate great reward because the
forgiveness is from Jum until the
following Jum all that week forgiven
sins. However, if a person does one
slight thing during this 30 minute
window, it will invalidate that reward.
And as the prophet said,
he will go home with nothing but two
handfuls of dirt.
So there's a little bit more to mention
about this narration. We will conclude
this tomorrow inshallah.
[Silence]
So this may be
dedicated.
[Arabic recitation]